As we got to our next game,
True Confessions.
Bad news for all the fakers
and phonies out there today.
Tuesday was True Confessions
Day, the one official holiday
of the year for Americans
to emerge
from their duplicitous shells
and reveal
the true contents
of their hearts.
So, comedians,
I'm gonna show you a celebrity,
and you're gonna tell me
what they would confess
on True Confessions Day.
First up, Mark Zuckerberg.
Mark Zuckerberg. Lauren.
He met his wife on Friendster.
How dare you?!
Points. Next up,
George R. R. Martin.
-Lauren. -He uses his parents'
HBO Go subscription.
Points.
Next, Oscar winner
Leonardo DiCaprio.
-Seth Morris.
-Thinks climate change is a lie.
-Oh, wow.
-Secretly.
Next, Harrison Ford. John.
He's actually never seen
an episode of Ally McBeal.
Not one episode.
He lives it, man.
Yeah.
Next up, One Direction.
Lauren.
-They love to practice kissing
on each other. -Oh!
-Points.
-That was great!
And finally, Katy Perry.
-Seth. -Nicknamed her asshole
Taylor Swift.
-They have bad blood.
-Oh.